good morning
I've just been to Buckingham Palace and
accepted his majesty the king's
invitation to form a government in his
name
it is only right
to explain why I'm standing here
as your new prime minister
right now
our country is facing a profound
economic crisis
the aftermath of covid still lingers
Putin's war in Ukraine has destabilized
energy markets and Supply chains the
world over
I want to pay tribute to my predecessor
Liz Truss
she was not wrong
to want to improve growth in this
country
it is a noble aim
and I admired her restlessness to create
change
but some mistakes were made
not born of ill will or bad intentions
quite the opposite in fact
mistakes nonetheless
and I have been elected as leader of my
party
and your prime minister
in part
to fix them
and that work begins immediately
I will place economic stability and
confidence
at the heart of this government's agenda
this will mean difficult decisions to
come
but you saw me
during covid doing everything I could to
protect people and businesses
with schemes like furlough
there are always limits
more so now than ever
but I promise you this
I will bring that same compassion
to the challenges we face today
the government I lead
will not leave the Next Generation
your children and grandchildren
were they debt to settle that we were
too weak to pay ourselves
I will unite our country
not with words
but with action
I will work day in and day out to
deliver for you
this government
will have integrity
professionalism
an accountability at every level
Trust
is earned and I will earn yours
I will always be grateful to Boris
Johnson for his incredible achievements
as prime minister
and I treasure his warmth and generosity
of spirit
and I know he would agree
that the Mandate my party earned in 2019
is not the sole property of any one
individual
it is a mandate
that belongs to and unites all of us
and the Heart of that mandate is our
Manifesto
I will deliver on its promise
a stronger NHS
better schools
safer streets control of our borders
protecting our environment supporting
our Armed Forces leveling up and
building an economy that Embraces the
opportunities of brexit where businesses
invest innovate and create jobs
I understand
how difficult this moment is
after the billions of pounds it cost us
to combat covert after all the
dislocation that caused in the midst of
a terrible war that must be seen
successfully to its conclusions
I fully appreciate how hard things are
and I understand too
that I have work to do to restore trust
after all that has happened
all I can say
is that I am not daunted
I know the high office I have accepted
and I hope to live up to its demands
but when the opportunity to serve comes
along
you cannot question the moment only your
willingness
so I stand here before you
ready to lead our country into the
future
to put your needs above politics
to reach out and build a government that
represents the very best traditions of
my party
together we can achieve incredible
things
we will create a future
worthy of the sacrifices so many have
made
and Phil tomorrow
and every day thereafter
with hope
thank you
[Music]
the United
[Music]
and you unite the party prime minister
which is in that the new prime minister
posing for a few photos after making his
speech on the steps of Downing Street it
was a speech directed at the public I
will work day in day out for you but he
also had a few words to say about his
predecessor at least trust had a noble
aim to improve growth but some mistakes
were made I've been elected to fix them
you can hear those Applause as he enters
number 10 as prime minister back that's
his team inside and you can hear them as
he goes in they all line up as you go in
and I'm sure we'll get pictures later of
him uh being ushered in uh with the new
team and a new start for number 10 again
uh the second prime minister to have
been appointed by the conservative party
without an election as many opposition
politicians are pointing out in a space
of just seven weeks